[Musique]
aujourd'hui mercredi 30 mars l'actualité
marquée par les 150 ans de la naissance
de léon blum au président au ministre
l'homme politique s'est éteint dans les
yvelines et son ancienne demeure
aujourd'hui musée vient de revenir sur
son héritage nous évoquerons aussi les
attentes des étudiants envers le
prochain président de la république
après les retraités les agriculteurs ou
encore les artistes nous donnons la
parole aux plus jeunes encore en
formation nous terminerons ce journal a
créé pierre où un promoteur immobilier a
fait le choix de transformer un château
à l'abandon en logements de standing
aperçu de ce qui attendra les héros
propriétaire mais pour débuter revenons
sur les violences subies par les élus
locaux avec deux invités les maires de
la verrière et de plaisir
[Musique]
près de 1200 élus ont subi au moins une
agression du ont durant les onze
premiers mois de 2000 21 parmi eux 600
mères victimes de violences verbales
voire physiques bonjour joséphine
coleman berger maire de plaisir et
bonjour nicolas mainville maire de la
verrière bonjour et merci à tous les
deux d'être venu en parler en plateau de
bonnes situations d'une réalité que vous
connaissez malheureusement bien on va
débuter avec vous joséphine coleman
bergé elle 23 mars dernier lors du
conseil municipal qui se déroulait en
visioconférence vous êtes en mairie avec
des agents de la municipalité et le
conseil municipal se passe pas forcément
très très bien il ya eu une éruption au
sein du conseil un peu d'agitation va
dire un peu d'agitation c'est un moindre
mot puisque on a pu constater derrière
les vitres puisqu'on a des grandes baies
vitrées et bien pas mal de personnes
venir avec des cagoules des masques des
haut parleurs des banderoles et puis
vociférations assez prégnante ça a duré
très longtemps et avec des gestes je
dirais dégorgement qui était assez
inquiétant j'avoue que les agents qui
étaient avec moi étaient tétanisés par
cette violence je n'ai pas interrompu le
conseil municipal parce qu'il n'en était
pas question j'ai pas question parce que
d'abord c'est une séance que l'on doit
respecter puis d'autres pas nous avons
aussi je dirais nos convictions par
rapport aux quartiers nous souhaitons
améliorer ce quartier le but voilà pour
préciser vous étiez en pleine discussion
autour d'une délibération concernant le
quartier du val ebooks et en plaine en
pleine mutation et c'est à ce moment là
que effectivement parfois des très
jeunes vous ont interpellé très très
jeune oui il ya des jeunes adultes après
il ya des adultes qui encadrent tout ça
mais il ya des quand même parfois même
des enfants ce qui est assez inquiétant
je trouve et puis et puis des personnes
que nous connaissons et qui font partie
je dirais de l'opposition et c'est
dommageable parce que moi je compte
j'accepte la contestation où les
critiques mais je considère que rien ne
doit être accompagnée de violences donc
à partir de ce moment-là toute
discussion est ouverte on a toujours été
ouvert alors c'est vrai que ces deux
années de pandémie n'ont pas permis de
grande concertation mais à partir du
mois d'avril et c'était déjà bien
anticipés avant même le conseil
municipal il doit y avoir plus d'une
trentaine de concertation avec les
habitants pour travailler sur ce projet
nicolas la ville vous aussi vous avez
rencontré le même genre de situation et
vous les rencontrez encore je pense à
cet épisode aussi de 2 l'an dernier
quartier du bois de l'étang quartier qui
lui aussi du côté de la verrière doit
être profondément modifié votre tueur a
été caillassée vous avait été pris à
partie également c'est vrai qu'on a des
situations un petit peu similaire avec
ma collègue de plaisir parce que ce sont
deux quartiers dont les tendances sont
inquiétants si on ne fait rien et on a
courageusement décidé mala de prendre le
taureau par les cornes de de rénover ce
quartier qui en a vraiment besoin et on
fait face à une petite minorité qui veut
pourrir la situation que ce soit des
gens qui ont des habitudes parce que à
l'abri des regards indiscrets ils
peuvent s'adonner à tout un tas de
trafic parce que il ya aussi une
récupération politique
parce qu'il ya d'autres intérêts et
c'est vrai qu'il ya une vraie forme de
violence effectivement véhicule a été a
été caillassée c'était quand même un
moment avec une collègue on était
ensemble qui nous a marqués on a des
agents qui ont porté plainte
j'ai moi même porté plainte plusieurs
fois pour des menaces on a eu une
réunion publique
d'ailleurs le préfet était présent où
j'ai dû être exfiltré ou un de mes
adjoints a été traitée de harkis comme
comme si ces nouvelles menaces nouvelles
insultes à la mode pour dire que c'est
un traître il ya eu aussi des dd des
insultes sale pour certaines élus
des habitants qui se sont rendus à la
réunion et qui ont du
voile à revenir chez eux tellement
l'ambiance était était délétère
le préfet qui n'avait jamais vu ça
qu'ils n'avaient jamais vu ça qui du
coup pense ou avec les partenaires que
le quartier ressemble ce qu'il a vu
alors que le karité du bois de l'étang
comme le quartier du val du goût c'est
beaucoup plus a lancé beaucoup de
personnes qui ont envie que ça bouge et
sertic mauvaise réputation parce qu'il
est plusieurs faits divers qui s'y sont
produits mais une fois plus c'est pas
une effectivement cession totale de la
population qui opère dans la très grande
majorité des habitants ce sont des vrais
talents et puis pour terminer aussi des
personnes extérieures qui sont mobilisés
dans ces quartiers je pense au fameux
adama traoré qui a quand même été
mise en cause et puis mise en examen
pour apologie du terrorisme et des
personnalités qui sont particulières
quand on les voit dans un quartier est
qui qui jettent de l'huile sur le feu
qui sont là pour exciter tout le monde
et pour insuffler climat de haine de
haine envers les élus et ça c'est très
grave oui vous parler de haine
aujourd'hui et vous parlez aussi du
préfet qui n'avait jamais vu ça par
exemple aujourd'hui tous les verrous ont
sauté il n'y a plus aucune limite je
vous donne comme exemple la venue de m
dames nadia ministre en charge de la
politique de la ville et qui a subi
exactement les mêmes choses quand elle
est venue sur le quartier quelques mois
puisque on avait pratiquement les mêmes
individus qui sont venus qui ont empêché
carrément de faire le tour du quartier
alors qu'elle était là dans cette
démarche de réhabilitation et même lors
de la réunion la réunion a été
véritablement polluer mais pas par ces
individus ce que je voudrais dire en
accord avec nicolas dainville c'est que
on est dans une démarche très positif
sur le quartier et on est dans une
reconnaissance de la majorité des
habitants du quartier qui sont des
personnes exceptionnelles mais qui sont
effectivement pollué par tout ça sont
les personnes qui étudient qui
travaillent qui ont de véritables
actions au sein du quartier par le biais
d'associations et qui sont dans une
constructivité vraiment positive et
c'est quand même dommage de voir que
dans un quartier comme celui là et comme
chez toi qui est un groupuscule qui crée
un peu la panique parce que c'est vrai
que ils sont capables de faire du
porte-à-porte ils sont capables
détricoter tout ce qu'on essaye de faire
et surtout d'informer les gens sur toute
une série de choses très mensongère donc
c'est compliqué donc pas de violence
discussions on se rencontre mais surtout
pas de violence c'est ce qu'on essaie de
faire passer comme message à jean picq
d'une évolution ces deux dernières
années avec la situation de confinement
aussi situation qu'ovide situation de
crise d -g les auges dit les jaunes
aussi pardon il ya eu beaucoup de
tension ces deux trois dernières années
et sur le début de ce nouveau mandat de
maire est-ce que ça explique en partie
aujourd'hui qu'il n'y ait plus de freins
plus de verrous et qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on ne discute plus en fait
ça n'explique pas et ça ne pardonne pas
et ça ne se justifie pas oui on a tous
été figé bloqué mais je ne pense pas que
ce soit sac effet je dirais déclenchée
parce que ça concerne toutes les
communes à travers la france entière
pour rester dans les yvelines on
pourrait citer le cas de 2.6 aussi avec
le maire karl olive qui a été menacé
plusieurs fois de mort et puis on sait
aujourd'hui que les maires sont formés
avec l'association des maires de france
à désamorcer des conflits avec l'aide du
gign et 15000 maires et adjoints former
jusqu'à présent pour répondre à votre
question on a fait quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de concertation même avec le la
visioconférence les porte à porte qui
permettait de respecter quand même un
certain nombre de règles sanitaires donc
c'est pas du tout un manque de dialogue
du bien au contraire vous avez vraiment
une minorité de gens tout cas dans nos
deux quartiers qui veulent courir le
projet le collectif du bois de l'étang
pour les sites est associée avec la cgt
est avec eux le parti communiste
français ils font leurs manifestations
ensemble il empêche parfois les gens de
venir aux réunions publiques qui se met
devant le figaro l'a raconté dans un de
ses articles
il ya une volonté vraiment de de
s'approprier le quartier d'empêcher tout
changement et de s'en prendre aux élus
et voir aux habitants qui soutiennent le
projet moi j'ai beaucoup d'habitants qui
tient la sound alarme qui
parfois ne porte pas plainte tellement
ils ont peur que ça mène nulle part il
ya même des actes racistes nos gardiens
du bois de l'étang on leur a craché
dessus on a proféré des insultes
racistes à leur égard dochia un climat
où nos agents portent plainte ou le
personnel des bailleurs tire la sonnette
d'alarmé ou les maires les élus sont
quand même très inquiet où on a beau
porter plainte les plaintes sont peu
suivies de faits et c'est vrai que tous
nos élus qui sont confrontés à ce type
de projet courageux en paye les pots
cassés mais le garde des sceaux en 2020
eric dupond moretti avait demandé il ya
une circulaire qui était passé au parc
est destiné à renforcer les conséquences
pénales et judiciaire de ce type
d'agression vous constatez que ce n'est
pas efficace on attend on espère en tout
cas c'est pour le moment je peux pas
dire qui est grand changement c'est pas
quelque chose que l'on ressent
véritablement
on verra alors maintenant il ya un
espèce de statu quo en ce moment parce
que bon on est dans une période un peu
particulière donc on espère que derrière
il va y avoir un car moi je dis pas que
les élus doivent avoir je dirais une
reconnaissance particulière
mais malgré tout on représente la
population représente la république
française donc un moment donné je crois
que il faut qu'on soit vigilant de tout
cela est de nous accompagner mais malgré
tout ce que je voudrais dire je pense
que nicolas est d'accord avec moi on
lâchera rien vous quand même le savoir
on ne lâche rien moi ça fait sept ans
que je travaille sur ce projet 64
millions d'euros ont été apportées dans
le quartier est hors de question
aujourd'hui de remettre en cause de ça
on ne redonne repart pas à zéro sur ce
qu'on taxe on va discuter de tous les
projets mais je ne lâcherai rien je ne
suis pas intimider par ce genre de
choses je suis perturbée parce que c'est
violent parce que ça fait peur à mes
collaboratrices et à certains élus on a
on a un contrecoup qui est quand même
fort mais on ne lâchera rien en tout cas
moi je sais que nicolas et moi on ne
lâchera rien exactement on ne lâchera
rien ne cède pas face et c'est assez à
ces menaces
mais c'est vrai que vous avez des
pratiques qui sont quasiment
professionnelle en tout cas qu'ils ont
dû peut-être être exercée dans d'autres
cadres de boycott de sabotage de
réunions de concertation
de pourrissement et c'est vrai que c'est
très compliqué il faut pas céder aux
nounous non plus avec joséphine on ne
sait vraiment pas oui sur les violences
qui sont exercées envers les mères sur
ces deux cas particulier et plus
généralement
comment comment on peut malgré tout
l'expliqué en paradoxe parce que
auparavant est encore dans les derniers
sondages le maire et l'élu le plus
proche et le plus apprécié par la
population en général donc comment ça
reste le cas donc c'est un géant marre
et je pense que joséphine c'est pareil
le nombre de personnes qui vont dans mon
bureau qui me disent monsieur le maire
ce projet il est magnifique des bons on
en a besoin
j'ai même une personne qui m'a dit bon
vous ne verrez maniche mais j'ai
vraiment envie de partir j'ai des gens
qui manifestent mais qui en fait ont
fait des demandes de mutation pour aller
ailleurs vous avez beaucoup de gens qui
nous soutiennent qu'ils nous témoignent
d'un soutien très très fort et qui sont
en fait une très très large majorité
quand on a fait l'enquêté sociale pour
le bois de l'étang 74 % des habitants
interrogés sont pour le projet et vous
avez cette minorité qui pourrit les
choses mais qui est très politisée qui
mélange les genres et nous vous avez
vraiment une majorité de gens qui
soutiennent et donc effectivement l'élu
je pense qu'ils aiment aussi qu'on ne
cède pas il aime qu'on conçoit dans la
pédagogie qu'on se laisse pas faire
parce qu'on n'a pas le droit d'insulter
les autres mais coco contiennent la
barre avec pédagogie avec respect les
gens ont le droit d'être contre mais
voilà qu'on compte qu'on ne soit pas un
timide abl l'association des maires de
france évoque peut-être la nécessité
d'avoir une protection fonctionnelle
pour le statut d'élu bord de mer
particulièrement est ce que ce serait
déjà une une réponse une première
approche pourquoi pas pourquoi pas vous
savez plutôt que de parler de notre
protection moi j'aurais tendance à dire
pensons aux habitants les habitants du
quartier ils ont peur eux aussi parce
que comme disait nicolas ces
groupuscules la craie vraiment la
problématique dans les quartiers font
peur aux restes être que les autres
personnes n'osent pas bougé nous on
aurait tendance à moi personnellement
j'en étendre aux cantines et les
mouvements forts comme ça d'avoir un
contre-mouvement pas uniquement de l'élu
mais aussi des habitants de certains
élus qui sera de certains habitants qui
pourraient se regrouper pour dire
également et faire entendre leur voix
n'osent pas le faire parce qu'ils ont
peur d'être des actions qui peuvent être
contre eux contre leurs familes en
voiture là tout ce que vous voulez donc
et c'est ça kit est primordial
aujourd'hui oui nous on est important
parce qu'on a été reconnue mais qu'est
ce que ça veut dire important c'est
qu'on est porteur d'un projet peut-être
trois exemples jeu j'abonde
effectivement un climat doux presque de
terreur c'est à dire qu'ils ont une peur
bleue des représailles dont beaucoup de
gens même préfèrent signer les pétitions
d'opposants pour éviter d'avoir des
ennuis le lendemain de mon élection
il ya eu un appel en fait à faire le
dawa donc avec plusieurs véhicules ont
été incendiés plusieurs poubelles pour
bloquer l'accès du quartier le soir de
mon élection donc c'est quand même assez
terrible hein mais soutient qu'ils
m'avaient appelé publiquement à voter
pour moi à tutu vérifier c'est son
véhicule qui avait brûlé donc pour vous
donner vraiment le climat de terreur est
un autre exemple qui va marquer c'est un
maire de l'agglo qui parfois dans
certaines républiques mais un gilet pare
balles parce qu'il ya un tel climat de
menaces qu'effectivement il ya un moment
donné où il veut pas que sa vie
soit mise en danger une dernière
question dans deux semaines même pas
maintenant nous allons voter pour le
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle mais à la campagne en ce
moment et un temps de parole officielle
à respecter mais néanmoins j'aimerais
juste avoir votre votre souhait en tant
que élu local de premier plan qu'elle
est ce que vous attendez pour les cinq
prochaines années quel que soit le
président ou la présidente élue
j'attends qu'on fasse tout ce qu'on
avait prévu de faire et qui n'a pas été
fait parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
qui n'ont pas été faites alors on met
tout ça sous le sous le couvert de la
pandémie mme enfin la pandémie elle a
bon dos un moment donné les réformes de
l'état doivent se faire véritablement il
ya il ya une vraie problématique de
pouvoir d'achat qui
véritable qui s'éloigne peut-être un
petit peu de notre sujet d'aujourd'hui
mais c'est quelque chose d'important je
crois également que tout le travail
d'insertion dans les quartiers quelque
chose d'important mais pas de rejet on
n'est pas dans un discours de rejet on
est dans un discours d'insertion ont
fait suffisamment de choses aujourd'hui
je dirais nous les maires pour pouvoir
se sentir accompagné par l'état ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui l'état ne
nous accompagne pas suffisamment alors
il ya des choses qui sont faites je veux
pas non plus tôt d'émigrer mais il ya
aussi toute cette toutes ces démarches
la fève qui sont très importants
fauqué fois je dirais la réforme de la
justice c'est vrai que on a parfois les
maires à sentiment d'impuissance face
aux rodéos sauvages face aux
interpellations de jeunes qu'on retrouve
parfois l'a prédit l'après midi même
dans le quartier avec une lenteur du
traitement judiciaire qui est beaucoup
trop long
voilà il ya des jeunes qui seront jugées
parfois ce 4 6 mois après les faits donc
même la punition n'a plus de valeur
pédagogique
donc il faut je pense le que les petites
peines soient appliquées soient
prononcées beaucoup plus rapidement
qu'on ait une valeur pédagogique de la
peine
et puis voilà que cette réforme
judiciaire soit mené pour que
tout acte malveillant nous nous reste
plus impunis merci beaucoup à tous les
deux d'être venu sur ce plateau de tv 78
et nous poursuivons ce journal
[Musique]
le chantier de la nationale 10 à la
hauteur de trappes se poursuit avec
quelques perturbations encore depuis
deux nuits la circulation est
neutralisée sur la voie lente puis la
voie rapide un nouveau système de feu a
été mis en place rappelons que cinq ans
de travaux seront nécessaires pour
transformer cette partie de l'axé
routier amené à être recouvert afin de
recoudre les deux parties de la commune
[Musique]
sinon je ne participe et de look ans
c'est bien d'avoir organisé ça comme une
répétition générale pour l'une des
quatre classes de l'iut de menton en
yvelines en vue du concours d'éloquence
du lundi 4 avril prochain chaque
participant a pu choisir et écrire son
discours parmi une liste de sujets
proposés j'ai vu un peu tous les sujets
vérins qui m'intéressait j'ai vu que
trond sollied éthylomètre branché ça m'a
paru drôle et sympa à faire ch des prix
et c'est ce qui a d'ailleurs le discours
cela va de l'humour à des thèmes plus
mélancolique dont le thème portera sur
l'essence et la vie ça fait passer un
message peut être d'espoir à certaines
personnes et des messages aussi
d'encouragement voire même dénonciateurs
moi je parle de la maladie de mon
endométriose se trouvait le moyen du
monde connaisse mais que personne parle
de toi il est les hommes tuent des
gouttes et les femmes je le fais parce
que c'est un concours qui est proposé
par l'établissement et que j'ai été
sélectionné par un professeur de
techniques d'expression et de
communication ça apprend l'éloquence la
rhétorique le fait de pouvoir parler en
public pour l'organisatrice et
professeur corinne gaumont l'objectif de
l'événement est avant tout d'apprendre
certaines bases de la parole aux
quelques 200 étudiants participants
savoir parler savoir choisir les mots
justes les bons mots ce qui marque ce
qui émeuvent ce qui motive en fait pour
mes étudiants c'est avoir une longueur
d'avancé et donc il est important pour
moi de les entraîner et d'organiser ce
type d'événement au sein de l'iut de
mantes en yvelines outre l'expérience
apportée par l'exercice des récompenses
pour les prix mais un ipad un chèque de
200 euros et des places pour le zoo de
thoiry attribué par la directrice et
marraine de cette édition collombat de
la panoz
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle reine elle vit je
suis étudiant en troisième année de
droit à l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines par rapport aux
caïds kokovic c'était quand même assez
compliqué on a dû changer quand même
beaucoup d'habitudes par exemple moi
j'avais pas du tout l'habitude de
travailler chez moi travaillez jamais
chez moi j'étais je passais toutes mes
journées à la biotech en général et mes
week-ends aussi donc enfin vraiment tout
le temps et d'un coût de 2 voire
complètement changé de cadre c'est assez
compliqué sur la biotech ça vous fera
enquête est quand même assez agréable
sans ça c'était
c'était pas facile surtout quand on a
été pas mal livrés à nous-mêmes mon
colis des toubous donc c'est très très
peu encadré en plus on me disait que ça
allait être le diplôme à l'est rien
valoir que ça qu'est ce qui vous fait si
leur style cool car
là on est un peu en paix dans l'afrique
aux idées il ya un peu un truc de année
vous vous êtes la génération collier
donc vous êtes vous êtes nulle par
rapport aux autres vous avez pu le
niveau mais faute train de rattraper ce
niveau à ce niveau là par exemple la
plateforme on doit avoir taillé une
plateforme pour les admissions aux
masters je faisais mes jambes masters
c'est très compliqué c'est chaque fois
qui fait qui fait ce qu'elle veut c'est
chaque émission est géré comme la fac
elle en a envie typiquement son postulat
à 20 fac pour créer un compte quand on
crée nos comptes c'est en même temps de
faire nos devoirs on est en plein examen
côté et on a en plus des contacts et on
a deux mille trucs à faire donc déjà
cette plate forme ça serait quand même
ultra ultra avec important l'impression
que doit pas exister les étudiants tasse
on l'a toujours dit depuis surtout
because it des étudiants sont pas existé
ce qui est normal quand on essaye de
préserver l'économie à cause du peu vide
bah évidemment les étudiants
s'inscrivent à l'économie donc très
rapidement ses 500 des deux côtés
[Musique]
écrivain juriste politiciens homme aux
multiples facettes léon blum personnages
importants de l'histoire de france 9
avril 2022 date du 150e anniversaire de
sa naissance et pour l'occasion une
conférence débat était animé par un
enseignant doctorant en philosophie
politique à la salle du vieux marché à
jouy en josas de rappeler à cette
occasion à l'ensemble de sa vie mais
aussi d'essayer de sans trop forcer voir
la manière dont sept dans cette ville où
les différentes expériences de cette vie
peuvent résonner jusqu'à aujourd'hui à
la fois dans nous dans nos vies
personnelles et puis surtout dans notre
expérience politique collective le thème
de cette soirée léon blum quel héritage
aujourd'hui un aspect mémorielle mais
aussi des problématiques qui font écho
dans notre société actuelle il symbolise
au plus haut point des valeurs
d'attachement la république et notamment
la valeur de justice qui à mon avis est
une valeur essentielle
et puis il avait aussi une conception de
la france de la nationalité de la
citoyenneté qui parle beaucoup à la
période d'aujourd'hui je suis convaincu
je le dis assez souvent bloom aurait
trouvé les mots par rapport à tout le
débat qu'est ce qu'un citoyen qu'est ce
que l'identité
une centaine de personnes étaient
présents dans la salle pour l'historien
pascal ory il y a deux raisons de
commémorer la mémoire de léon blum c'est
un très bel exemple d'homme politique et
franchement on peut penser
qu'aujourd'hui mais c'est pas nouveau
dans les années 30 aussi l'homme
politique la politique les partis
politiques ne sont pas toujours
considéré de façon très favorable et
c'est profondément injuste à toutes les
époques vie deuxièmement parce que les
solutions qu'il propose qu'on peut
qualifier de social démocrate sont
peut-être pas tellement au devant de la
scène mais à mon avis quand on considère
ce qui se passe dans d'autres pays je
pense que il ya une philosophie
politique dont il faut tenir compte
cette soirée était organisée par la
mairie de jouer en josas et
l'association de la maison léon blum qui
a pour mission de faire vivre sa mémoire
à travers différentes manifestations
culturelles et bien évidemment à travers
sa demeure la maison léon blum se trace
se trouve dans le quartier des mets a
joué en josas donc sur les hauteurs ici
nous sommes bien dans la dans la ville
où léon blum a vécu les cinq dernières
années de sa vie si on veut comprendre
léon blum la maison dit beaucoup de
choses
une petite maison assez modeste le
bureau il est énorme à l'intérieur du
bureau il ya une table travail qui est
énorme et puis derrière son immense
bibliothèque la soirée en l'honneur de
léon blum s'est terminée par des
dédicaces avec les auteurs internement
[Musique]
je suis youri buratti le directeur
général du groupe ranger liste qui
s'occupe de restauration d'immeubles et
aujourd'hui je vous présentais le
château de crespières dans le 78 entre
orgeval et plaisir allez on y va
suivez-moi
[Musique]
il a été fini de construire fin du
xviiie siècle et ensuite il est passé de
famille en famille et le dernier
occupant qui a quitté les lieux en 1989
c'était donc michel bourbon de parme qui
est donc le petit fils du duc de parme
en bonbons gélis s'est porté acquéreur
et va maintenant rénover ce château lui
redonnant toutes ses lettres de noblesse
avec notamment 12 logements qui vont du
t3 au t4 duplex évidemment des places de
parking les travaux de rénovation sont
vraiment très très lourd puisque la
toiture est effondré les escaliers
intérieurs sont effondrés les planches
et aussi donc ça va nécessiter au
minimum 30 mois de travaux le château
est constitué de deux tours avec un
mythe pièce centrale et vous avez un
retour sur la tour de droite dans
laquelle il y aura également des
logements qui vont donc être achetés
soit par des gens qui veulent y habiter
soit des gens qui veulent faire de
l'investissement dans le cadre du
dispositif final c'est tout à fait
possible donc je pense qu'on aura aucune
difficulté à vendre du le cas de
magnifiques et la proximité notamment de
paris
donc là on arrive sur la partie arrière
du château où cette partie arrière sera
composée de petits jardins avec des
chemins carrossables pour les pour les
habitants
[Musique]
si c'est une des rares pièces
dans laquelle on peut rentrer sans se
prendre une pierre sur la figure donc on
voit les aspects arrondi
moi qui avais des tentures
dans un tas de choses intéressantes en
terme de décoration qui est évidemment
très dégradé on va pouvoir sortir cette
opération aux alentours de 5900 euros du
m
et si on rajoute les parkings ont servi
aux alentours de 6000 6100 euros
puisqu'il y aura de parking par par
logement
[Musique]
comme chaque fin d'année nos confrères
de tf1 organisent leur concours du plus
beau marché de france cette année pour
représenter les yvelines celui de
rambouillet talonneur première étape
remporté la sélection régionale face à
paris ou rueil malmaison le vote est en
cours jusqu'au 8 avril sur le site de la
chaîne le marché de rambouillet a vu le
jour au xvième siècle échanges troc
achats de légumes de fruits de volaille
constitué l'essentiel de l'activité
aujourd'hui le textile et est aussi à
l'honneur
[Musique]